las calles de la ciudad de Rush
permanecen bloqueadas en el noreste del
país estos iraníes gritan la palabra
libertad la base de todas sus demandas
dos meses después de la muerte de maxa
Mini asesinada por la policía iraní por
llevar mal puesto su Héroes islámico la
protesta contra el régimen no se
debilita
los cortes de internet y la censura de
los sitios web de noticias por parte de
las autoridades siguen siendo habituales
pero los videos continúan llegando a las
redes sociales como este en el que un
grupo de clérigos es desafiado por una
manifestante tengo que desaparecer es
eso sí Ahora sí ahora
pero la protesta siempre va acompañada
de una represión masiva por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad este miércoles la
justiciera ni continua muerte a tres
manifestantes en total cinco personas
han recibido esta pena desde el inicio
de las protestas el ministro del
interior iraní también mencionó la
detención de dos agentes de inteligencia
franceses una información inmediatamente
desmentida por el ministro de asuntos
exteriores francés Emmanuel abordó el
tema en el g20
Francia siempre ha respetado a los
dirigentes al pueblo iraní hemos buscado
siempre el diálogo el respeto pienso que
las decisiones que se han hecho en los
últimos meses no van en esta dirección
del lado de Irán y por lo tanto pido
volver a la calma respeto por la
estabilidad regional al respeto también
por los ciudadanos franceses
internacional
siete ciudadanos franceses están ahora
detenidos en las prisiones de la
República islámica por razones falsas
según indica París que pide su
Liberación inmediata